welcome back to big news with Josh
McKoon the only news source on the
internet that doesn't take itself too
seriously but just seriously enough to
hopefully get a sponsor someday looking
at you Jack Daniels it's 2019 and the
movie-going public eagerly awaits the
convenient plan of Tony Stark to undo
the Thanos snap the most impressive snap
since Jackson five and I want you back
also I can snap my fingers pretty
impressively see but before we see what
Kevin Feige drew up on his Russell Crowe
beautiful mind border being treated with
Hollywood's favorite star brie Larson
and her turn is Captain Marvel for those
not familiar with Captain Marvel she's a
captain who's marvelous and also for the
casual comic book fan not just a promo
tool for the Marvel brand which confused
my wife who said they have a hero named
after the company to which I respond
apparently I I don't know I don't make
the rules but wasn't brie Larson great
in 21 Jump Street that's what I thought
but I digress I'm here to give you
factual evidence that Captain Marvel is
in fact the love child of Tom Cruise and
Kelly McGillis and the rightful heir to
the Top Gun gun throne Captain Marvel is
being marketed as a marvel property set
in the 90s but without the iPhone how
can we actually tell the difference
between the 1990s and now honestly we're
dressed pretty much the same we all
still love blink 182 dr. Dre the
Motorola RAZR and gasps is still
something people complain about being
too expensive so I ask you how do I
prove that Captain Marvel is most
definitely the long-awaited sequel to
Top Gun I do it like this hit the music
pilots are famous for their sunglasses
aviator sunglasses to be exact
these sunglasses a product of the Ray
Ban Company have been scientifically
tested to withstand up to 130,000 G's of
force while in the cockpit of a Top Gun
jet plane and able to make people who
are already good looking even more
good-looking hence the reason when I put
them on I just look like a person that
shouldn't wear sunglasses the original
Top Gun sent the stock of Ray Ban and
the aviator sunglasses sky rocketing to
a hype the market was not ready for it
and in turn created the movie Wall
Street with all that being
and you'll notice that both Tom Cruise
and brie Larson are wearing aviators
they even pose with the exact same smile
the exact same cockpit of the exact same
plane sequel you betcha Craig did I just
say you betcha that's my man I'm Josh
are you basing your entire argument on
them wearing the same sunglasses no I'm
not
there's also the fact that Jude Law was
originally supposed to play Merlin
instead of Tim Robbins and is now
playing a character named Marvel Merlyn
Marvel Merlyn Marvel Merville Marlins
space fish earth water fish also jhula
was in the holiday which is an
underrated holiday classic and it's also
well known in the Scottish coastal
communities that he's a fantastic beach
volleyball player who loves to wear only
jeans and no shirt have you seen the
holiday though for those that haven't
it's a Christmas romantic comedy with a
lovely theme as a youngest Jack Black I
don't know he kind of always looks the
same Kate Winslet's as what Rose would
be as an editorial writer unlucky in
love Cameron Diaz's Charlie's Angel and
of course Jude Law as Jude Law in his
only biopic clearly though the most
relevant piece of edited evidence that
Captain Marvel is in fact the Top Gun
sequel is the famous thumbs up picture
of Maverick and the now iconic frame of
Captain Marvel with this hand signal
most people would say hey Josh this is
actually the hang-loose hand signal
which I would reply maybe or it could
mean one of three things you're in
Hawaii you once took a surfing lesson or
you're giving us that secret hand signal
that you're in the second movie aka the
sequel to Top Gun
let's take a look maverick Marvel
Maverick Marvel Maverick Marvel maverick
Marvel and who is this look at the last
name Rambo yeah it spelled different but
that's probably because her dad has been
in Southeast Asia her entire life and
she refuses to get familial
consideration when climbing the military
ranks do I smell crossover event shared
universe franchise perhaps these pilots
were so familiar with the alien world
that they knew what was coming
War of Independence Day and Top Gun was
a prequel to Independence Day crossover
with a sequel to Top Gun to explain the
aliens Independence Day think that's
outrageous so outrageous that Clark
Gregg is actually playing Tom Skerritt
brother it's almost too convenient to
think otherwise also there's a scene in
the holiday where an older man clad is
climbing the stairs and I swear it
brings even the most stoic man to tears
after all of these reasons if you're
still not convinced that Captain Marvel
is not the Top Gun sequel her cat's name
is goose now for those that aren't up on
their Canadian mythology of the Canadian
goose it's said that most geese are
reincarnated as casts so when goose dies
in Top Gun it's perfectly clear that he
is then reincarnated as Captain Marvel's
cat and if you look closely the cat
Pope's definitely looks like Anthony
Edwards
he was great in ER now brie Larson nor
Tom Cruise have come out and admitted to
this being the sequel to Top Gun and fan
theories are exploding like a frog with
a firecracker in his mouth from that kid
in your neighborhood who will most
definitely try and sell you drugs in
high school and more than likely have to
face time from a federal penitentiary
for your 10-year class reunion but here
at Collider we have a team of private
investigators staked out with local gear
airfields all over the country and of
course outside Kelly Lynch's house wait
sorry Kelly LeBrock so sorry kelly
mcgillis is house to record any secret
meetings between Captain Marvel and
captain maverick we have yet to see
anything and actually have been told by
a local law enforcement that the
neighbors are getting upset and to
please leave but at Collider were
nothing if not persistent yeah so is
Captain Marvel a sequel to Top Gun
masters a Marvel movie is the Top Gun
sequel they're supposedly shooting
actually a fake shoot in order to throw
us off of the biggest movie reveal in
history and what was Independence Day
resurgence all about honestly
questions questions that almost seemed
too good to be true to answer but too
bad to be false to deny
this is fake news with josh mokuba
permission to buzz the tower
you